I'd like to take the Disney lyrics quiz
and I'm gonna be terrible at this
I'm really good at picking songs from
Disney's nervous-like behaviour and I
think most of the night time you know a
reasonably big Disney fan but I feel
like I really know like one song for
would be maybe I know the songs I just
don't think I know the lyrics and I just
kind of say in my own way in the shower
[Music]
let's do it
I don't even remember this part of the
song stare you stare at me well what I
do to see you looking at me staring
spooky so it's probably looking well
though this is a creepy ass movie so it
could be staring it's smiling okay
it's creepy to stare at someone who's
not going to smile like that I guess
that would make sense
smile too hard it's still creepy alright
so
I don't know this movie at all I never
saw this movie
the way
[Music]
yeah okay understand what she wants I
just don't know how she says she's so
misunderstood or Belle I've got one
oh no I haven't even seen this movie
[Music]
that's way confusing I would never want
to take breakfast
this is another one where I'm just gonna
have to logic my way through songwriting
along okay I'm inside from the great
unknown where I belong where I long to
be the sort of as an intern I'm Stan I
guess that makes that she has the female
heroine she should be going and doing
all this
where I go along different in my
programming and rhymes the wrong part of
the world except for like one words here
and it's like actually two words or
three is it grandma isn't she like
singing during that fair my spirits will
help my team to fly and we go there's an
eagle in the background she does I feel
like a terrible nineties kid I can't do
[Music]
could be you know escape from the cool
inside of because she's got like this
coldness going on that's making him
freak
cold cold she's dead inside like me
she's cold and dead no escape from the
cold inside me it was cold she's
literally frozen so me kelsier time for
one four six I said our Theory bad at
this and like always I didn't surprise
myself whatsoever
usually the real answer was a lot better
than whatever I came up with probably
should have my Disney season pass but
it's making me like remember I need to
see mallanna I need to go over you watch
off I'm gonna have to go home and watch
all these movies I shall watch tangled
again but that's pretty good maybe we
should just watch them all together this
weekend
[Music]